[Music]
okay I like this is the switch to the
best laid plans file but not this one
that's right guys this week on best of
we're talking about everybody's favorite
talent assassin Emily Lacroix aka
Widowmaker
now you guys already know Widowmaker can
make short work of squishy targets and
is an asset to just about any team comp
she can fit into and with Oh W Elsie's
into well underway we thought it would
be the perfect time to bring you the
very best of Widowmaker now get ready
sit back and watch as the lights of pine
carpe and more pull off some
death-defying acrobatics and of course
some elbow breaking flicks that funny
goes 0 for soul here oh he's hitting
shots like that
that is just too bad this what do you do
and that really puts Shanghai under a
long pressure now does that have to
first heal them up
only have mercy that's about as fast as
you hear them sit again so I don't
really feel like that
all right fit a flank you find I see you
there and John on via I needed you do I
picked up the account they wrapped me
around the backside he's found another
but ultrix missing my q3 Friday tqt take
for the widow that could coming to life
and that'll do it carpe right now okay
Bo drops dangerously low Harvard's
probably a bit of a volley they're
coming in from supe there you go Sian
play rewarded with one follows it up on
a kill and now he's looking to cut them
off as they retreat sure enough there it
is boom box is dead - no it's bad Ziya
player links her with that super charger
kind of once the Rangers at the damage
boost but pay attention the tire the
tire put the fear of God in them and
they had to use the bell to be Early's
ever wanted to get kidding me
so now and dad is going to try to find a
sneaky angle here they're still looking
for it they do pop in up top on the time
now they've created the chaos of perhaps
undead can hit some shots sick opening
there the coordination was too quick
[Applause]
there you go crowd that's right howl is
there and it changes the way you play is
a pure Dodd comp without been him doing
anything really just existing window
maker in a car with the two monster
kills and he continues to do the damage
three kills for carp and now he's gone
close eventually you're just gonna get
all picked off
carface shuts it down from the back line
he's gotta be your priority number one
right now and look at it and just take
another angle
[Applause]
always with a high-energy chunking down
Shields is gonna try to get out now fare
these games this life is they look to
get back hit yet again though dia takes
downlink sir gets the better of him and
it came but Houston they were saying it
before going into this match we need a
count on our team play don't play
play the DM game let's count on our team
play cos it's better than theirs in
foresight is up for the NYX l Widowmaker
is going to use it right away on the
road alpha Delson of the big pick there
on the jerk tracks then why mine finds
to pick on the profit though ng out of
commission three steps up to the plate
and hits a grand slam
not many widow-makers would go for this
play but I would just absolutely nails
it here even if she got one up this guy
is a living highlight real man control
meter building valiant kind of scattered
suit a little bit low health trying to
find the but talk about reactions but a
heat here can be very difficult friend
to get anything going ten seconds left
speed is not suitable defense three for
three in feta slapped the gold it down
so everyone you've know that he's your
pocket you know that he's to carry and
everyone's in on the action and that's
why he makes it look so easy
unbelievable just not missing a single
shot all headshots headshot boom
headshot boom headshot under shake
flower there with a volley of
destruction orbs now flower looking for
the lines the United States has to react
to this they have to fight outside of
sight lines while right now this is a
good perch doesn't have to make shield
to worry about cool Pat or D team backed
this is a decent opening here from South
Korea but Jay takes the soldier
the jump rope this time Jake doing a
lotta work Sinatra now brought back to
group that's the size that he is going
to be the anti mercy take stop both the
presser active euros here with the
vision to get behind cover your board
needs to control otherwise put alongside
the boss stop rising it too busy trying
to take the point that's the widow dual
one again Philadelphia future go and try
to come out the top striker though
there's a big strip on the garage there
the graviton helped me both supports are
called together that's what they need
avatar pace truck scene again what are
you doing
[Applause]
so he comes through that show Vanya P
has already killed I believe Necco in
mistakes we solve one shot on the nickel
then he kills mistakes now he comes
through the shots on the striker into
kelex there my lord is that good
meanwhile uber will come around the side
fires that scatterer and just gonna
damage Owen pie fine soon getting that
pig that he was looking for Custer there
with the res of course but finds out yet
oh and soon so I'm just gonna say super
lucky time already
somehow someway you know into the pit I
was gonna say fell to the pit here who
carpe gets the couches I found a baby
they'd knock freeze my bow that that
goes down all carp a totally going wild
on this Widowmaker right now and shake
especially when he comes in for those
emps make sure however gonna find the
first kill and be gonna be take him down
now rocky we saw this from him at the
World Cup in Incheon this man is out of
control gets another shot there on to
aid butter a little bit of
the ground yet
I came we don't make you this is taking
me back now
okay seize the trap fishers drop from
the high ground so you needed somebody
who can cast erisa shield Boykin
boundlessness is still relatively
durable faster oh that's the golden shot
three kills with a winner Mike yup now
that Delos feel I've found the key so
far away is gonna be behind the entire
team RESPA schemes just waiting to come
out here but they've got a frag surprise
waiting up top and I get out here at
some point in time side getting back in
position do not accept it there it is
they have no idea Steph pseudo has no
idea out to calvo for side player he'll
be able to just completely cut the legs
out from under Philadelphia fusion and
now Philly the pressure is on can they
deliver No
well guys that is it for the very best
of Widowmaker at least so far now if you
want to see more content like this
for example us doing a best-of on your
favorite overwatch hero well you already
know what to do headshot that like
button then of mine the subscribe button
and of course grapple hook into the
comment section to show us some love and
we'll see you next week
and with OWI l season 2 [ __ ] this is
gonna be hard intro we have to say Emily
lacrosse so much Emily lacrosse Boyle
Emily Lacroix family Lacroix Emily look
at the Black Rock Black Rock Mack Ross
[Music]
yes we are we are